good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the 2021 yale university
joint military commissioning ceremony we
are gathered here today to continue a
tradition rooted in military history and
custom
today we celebrate these young men and
women joining the ranks of those in our
armed forces
who have commissioned before them we
would like to thank
all of you gathered here today for
supporting these new officers
and joining us for this momentous
occasion there are several moments in
this ceremony
when it is appropriate to stand for the
arrival of the official party
the national anthem the invocation and
the departure of the official party we
ask that you now silence all electronic
devices the ceremony will begin shortly
ladies and gentlemen please rise for the
arrival of the official party and remain
standing for the national anthem
and invocation
colonel george r granholm united states
air force commander
air force rotc detachment 9 yale
university
captain ronald l withrow united states
navy
commanding officer naval rotc yale
university
today's honored guest and keynote
speaker president salve
president of yale university
scott a strobel provost of yale
university
kimberly m goff cruz secretary and vice
president for student life
yale university
marvin chun dean of yale college
[Applause]
sharon mk coogler yale university
[Applause]
chaplain
so
oh say can you
see by the dawn's early light
what so proudly well
at the twilight's last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
through the perilous fight
or the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly
streaming and the rockets red glare
the bombs bursting in
air gave proof
through the night that
our flag was still there
oh save us that star-spangled
banner yet way
or the left of the free
and the home
of the prey
chaplain coogler will now deliver the
invocation
almighty and gracious god
it is you who are all powerful and
loving
it is you who calls us to our full
humanity
today may we feel thoroughly embraced by
your presence
as we accept a new and daunting
responsibility
we understand this commissioning as both
blessing
and burden walk with us as we seek to be
light in the darkness
striving to be generous merciful and
just
enable us to act morally and with
boldness
to defend and foster the equality of a
person
the hopes of a people the justice of the
ages
merciful god as we begin our lives as
leaders
in this time fraught with uncertainty
bestow upon us the spirit of wise
judgment
and courage the spirit of good counsel
and strength the spirit of patient
knowledge
and reverence eternal god may our
greatest triumphs always be discovered
as we walk in your light as your beloved
children from many families of faith
may we be ever inspired by the spirit of
service
we witness on this day and all days
for this we say amen
please be seated
at this time i'd like to welcome captain
withrow commanding officer
of naval rotc at yale university
good afternoon everyone
thank you chaplain coogler for your kind
and thought-provoking invocation
uh you've certainly set the stage for
what is uh sure to be a dignified event
and uh wow certainly is a beautiful day
outside isn't it
uh it's great there's a little bit of a
breeze here uh welcome everyone both in
person and in simulcast land out there
a special welcome to president salovey
provost strobel dinchan
secretary and vice president goff cruz
uh thank you for allowing us to host
this in-person event we really
appreciate this
also welcome to the deans and heads of
college uh also dean levesque and
and dean soti as well uh and also thank
you
for those uh for your incredible support
to our rotc programs over the course of
the past year in the many years uh
previous
uh i'd also like to ascend a a welcome
to uh the members of the yale veterans
association
thank you for all that you have done for
midshipmen and cadets as well
to the staffs of the naval and air force
rotcs
commissioning marks the culmination of
years of your hard work fulfilling
our mission to train and develop these
midshipmen and cadets
into military officers so well done
um i also wanted to say uh to say
welcome uh to retired
admiral joe callow and his wife retired
captain sally mackel reef callow
they're watching from afar in new york
city admiral callow is yale naval otc
class of 1958 uh he's also a benefactor
to naval rotc unit
in fact their gracious endowment in
small part was used to purchase
commissioning kits for each of the
midshipmen
definitely alleviating some of the the
financial burden of initial uniform
outlays so thank you admiral and sally
and saving the best for last a special
welcome to the parents and loved ones of
our midshipmen and cadets who are
watching from afar
maybe from across the plaza back there i
believe so another round of applause
so what do i say to an intrepid group of
incredibly talented and spirited men and
women about to embark on their careers
in our nation's marine corps navy air
force and space force
simply this you are ready now get to
work
now this is not the end of my remarks
still got a couple pages to go here
so of course i'm going to expound a bit
your entire life you have been
developing your personal virtues and
leadership traits
you have your parents coaches teachers
rotc staff
religious leaders amongst others to
thank for that but you should also enjoy
personal satisfaction knowing your
perseverance creativity
thirst for knowledge are also
significant factors in you sitting here
today
it's taken a lot of hard work to get to
this point the starting point of your
military careers
and it will take a lot more hard work on
your part and on the part of the teams
you will lead
and midshipman i checked the latest
revision to us navy regulations before i
came here
i didn't see any prohibition against
hard work so hard work is still
authorized
hard work is authorized but so is smart
work
you're all well aware of this after
having navigated the the past year plus
we live in an era of revisionist powers
challenging our role as a democratic
leader
and defender of freedom and democracy
around the world challenging our
security interests and those of our
allies and seeking to consume weaker
nations
this requires our military to be strong
and smart you must be strong and smart
in 1630 john winthrop leading puritan
figure and first governor of the
massachusetts bay colony spoke of
massachusetts
and his early settlers as a city on the
hill a shining example to the world
his clearing call has continued to
define our nation but ours is a tenuous
position
requiring the resolve and commitment of
our people our elected officials
and our nation's military when called
upon to deter those
who wish ill upon us our allies and our
shared interest
and when necessary to confront them you
midshipmen have learned of the critical
role sea power
and maritime strategy plays in the
defense of our city on the hill our
nation the ideals we hold dear
and our allies you have been introduced
to the critical role of joint teamwork
with our fellow services such as the air
force and space force
and with our partner nations sea power
requires people power
and strong leadership your leadership so
today in about 30 minutes you will
recite the oath of office
soaring loyalty to our constitution and
the country whose course it directs
then donning the cloth of our nation and
with seabag in hand
you will embark on the journey of a
lifetime as a naval officer
i rest easy knowing you are taking the
helm because i know you are ready
and because i know you will continue to
work hard and smartly
to our midshipmen and this is the last
time that i will refer to you as
midshipman
i know i speak on behalf of the staff of
naval rotc when i say i'm incredibly
proud
of your achievements and greatly look
forward to watching from ashore
as you cast off all lines and get
underway you are an extremely talented
and promising group of leaders
warriors with certainly a few budding
admirals and generals in the in the mix
i'm sure
so muhammad valente k
bella sophia charlie and jacob
u2 allegra in short order welcome to the
officer's mess and the wardroom
thank you
at this time i'd like to welcome colonel
granholm commander of air force rotc
at yale university
thanksgiving thank you kid ruggle set
so good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
uh
today is indeed a special day for our
graduates
both for the journeys that they are
about to take and for the obstacles
they have overcome over the past four
years
i think we can all agree that this year
has been unlike any other
in the history of rotc at yale
it's been a year of immense challenges
and personal loss for many of us here in
the audience
we have lost family and friends and
family members
we have faced financial and professional
disruptions
and we have struggled to maintain
personal connections via zoom
while sequestered away from each other
for over a year now
yet with all that we have faced i think
it is even
more important for us to come together
today
and celebrate this momentous occasion as
the members of the rotc
class of 21 affirm their willingness to
support and defend our country
as commissioned officers i'd like to
first acknowledge the incredible support
that we receive from the yale community
demonstrated by the presence of our
distinguished guests today
president salvi thank you for your
personal engagement on behalf
of our cadets provost strobel
secretary goff cruz and chaplain coogler
i greatly appreciate your presence here
today
and your support of our otc program
dean chun thank you for helping our
students
through the many challenges they have
faced this year and for
expediting numerous special requests for
essential military training
thank you to the deans and heads of
colleges who
have joined us today for your patience
in dealing with
arcane military paperwork and for the
personal care and concern that you have
shown for your
students thank you also to adrian
henry and sean representing the yale
veterans association and the yale
veterans network
for all the support you've given our
cadets financial and otherwise
i'd also like to recognize our rotc
liaisons george levesque and risa soti
who not only have been forced to learn
air force and navy lingo and acronyms
but who also work tirelessly to advocate
on our behalf
with the larger yale community
along with the air force and navy cadre
who made the ceremony possible today
i'd like to especially highlight our two
planning leads
cadet anne northrup and cadet molly
rogelstedt
i think we can all agree that they
deserve the most credit of anyone
in making this ceremony possible thank
you for volunteering
and to all of you joining us via the
live stream
including the friends and families of
our graduating cadets and midshipmen
welcome so to our air force rotc class
of 2021
you are about to take the next step on a
journey
shared by men and women in uniform since
the continental army was established in
1775
an army which included students who
stood just steps away from here
on their commencement day two and a half
centuries ago
you have all heard me say probably a few
times
that rotc is first and foremost a
leadership program
that regardless of what job you are
going to do in the air force or space
force
you will all be leading our airmen and
guardians
in accomplishing your assigned mission
fortunately for those airmen and
guardians
we have an incredible group of leaders
in the class of 21.
your leadership is what allowed our
cadet wang
to overcome the countless challenges we
faced this year
to create an entirely new hybrid
training program at a few weeks notice
and to do it all with a positive
attitude and can do spirit
you have you have innovated you have
raised the intensity
when necessary and you have shown our
first and second year cadets how
to lead but what i am most grateful for
is the care and concern you have
demonstrated for your fellow cadets
you have internalized the most important
attribute you will need as a military
leader
putting the needs of the team above your
own
almost 105 years ago 12 yale students
founded the yale aero club
which later formed the nucleus of the
first yale unit
when they took their oaths on march 24
1917
at the naval submarine base in new
london they probably could not imagine
that their service would bring them to
the battlefields of belgium and france
in under a year i know that when i was
commissioned in 1998
i would not have predicted that a little
over three years later
the united states would embark on the
longest war
in our history a war for which i and
most of our qadri members here today
have deployed multiple times as well as
some of the veterans
with the yva and yvn
for all of you about to join our
nation's officer corps today
i do not know where and how you will
serve or
if your service will lead you into
combat
what i do know after spending the past
year with you
is that i am confident you will serve
with honor and distinction
and will lead our air force and space
force through whatever challenges we
face in the years to come
i congratulate each of you and i thank
you for the spirit of service
on behalf of our great nation
it is now my great pleasure to introduce
dr peter salovey
23rd president of yale university and
the chris argyros professor of
psychology
it is entirely fitting that president
salovey is our guest of honor today
his groundbreaking work with john d
mayer on emotional intelligence
is used widely across the department of
defense
and is now an integral part of how the
air force trains our future leaders
president salve has been a strong
supporter of the rc rotc program at yale
and going back to his time as an intern
at the west haven va medical center
he truly understands issues facing our
veterans
and active duty military members ladies
and gentlemen
thank you president salve
good afternoon everyone it's truly an
honor to
be here to congratulate the class of
2021 of the
yale reserve officers training corps and
thank you
colonel granholm and captain withrow for
inviting me
to do so to all the families and friends
and loved ones
watching via live stream you're very
close to our hearts
on behalf of my wife marta and my
colleagues across the university
thank you for all you have done to
support these cadets
or graduates and finally to the rotc
class of 2021 thank you for your
commitment to yale
to the united states to the common good
we're proud of all you've accomplished
at this university
but even more we are grateful for your
service
soon you will not only graduate from
yale but also receive your commissions
into the united states armed forces
you will affirm your allegiance to the
constitution of the united states of
america
and pledge to defend our democracy
you take on this responsibility at a
critical moment
in our nation's history the coven 19
pandemic continues to claim lives
around the world the geopolitical
effects of this crisis will be
felt for years to come
we face other challenges extremism
sectarian violence environmental
catastrophe
poverty and yet in spite of these and
other serious threats
i'm encouraged by what i see talented
promising courageous men and women
you've worked hard at yale in your
classes
in your rotc training you've made
personal sacrifices in the service
of a larger goal to make our nation and
our world safer
and more secure you have done this not
just for yourselves in fact not for
yourselves
but for others not only for the present
but for future generations
although you have chosen a difficult
path
you do not go at it alone you join a
great legacy of military service at this
university
you go in the footsteps of nathan hale
yale college class of 1773
and revolutionary war hero and of course
van rensselaer creed the first
african-american to earn his medical
degree from yale
creed graduated in 1857 and joined the
union
army as soon as he was permitted to
enlist
you go in the footsteps of rear admiral
grace hopper
who earned her phd at yale when she
retired from the navy
at the age of 79 amazing grace
was the oldest serving officer
in the u.s armed forces
and he tread the path walked by many
others whose names are
not familiar to us nearly 30
000 yale graduates served in the first
and second world wars
in korea and vietnam
others have fought in recent wars and
serve around the globe today
your service honors those who have made
the ultimate sacrifice
in defense of this country
the names of over a thousand yell alumni
killed in wars since the american
revolution are carved into the walls
of memorial hall right over there
the freedoms we hold dear the prosperity
we
enjoy were made possible by previous
generations of military
service people i know your decision to
accept a commission in the united states
armed forces has not been made lightly
you've already given up many comforts
and conveniences
and you will give up many more in the
years ahead
thank you thank you for showing us by
your example
what it looks like to make sacrifices
for the common good
today as we recognize your achievements
we also mark another important milestone
ten years ago yale college voted
to restore the rotc to yell
i'm very proud of this decision it is
only right
that a university with such a rich
history of service
should welcome the rotc on our campus
and over the past decade we have worked
with our military partners to prioritize
the yale rotc
program and expand support and
opportunities
for veterans
each cadet contributes to this community
you bring distinctive perspectives and
experiences
to our campus you challenge and inspire
your fellow students faculty
and staff the rotc's presence brings
great honor to yale
but its importance is much broader
the partnership between universities and
the military
serves the country's long-term strategic
interests
yale and the us military prepare leaders
for the great challenges ahead yale will
continue to advocate
for funding and support for the rotc
as we educate students for careers in
every sector including the military
today i joined with so many others in
applauding
your commitment and your courage
you leave here taking what you have
learned at yale
and sharing it with a world in great
need
of light and truth
thank you all for what you have done
thank you all for what you will do to
fulfill yale's mission
to improve the world today and for
future generations
congratulations yale rotc class
of 2021
thank you president salabe we sincerely
appreciate you being with us today
cadets and midshipmen please take your
places on the stage
ladies and gentlemen we have now come to
the part of the ceremony for which these
midshipmen and cadets have worked for
over the past four years the oath of
office
would everyone please rise as the oath
of office is administered to those being
commissioned as officers in the marine
corps
navy air force and space force
um
oh
without any mental reservations
god
[Applause]
second lieutenants and enzymes will pin
on their new ranks in private ceremonies
with friends
and family
thank you all for commemorating this
occasion please be seated
captain withrow colonel granholm and
president salovey will now present the
commissioning certificates to the new
ensigns and second lieutenants
adrian bonnenberger the president of the
yale veterans association
will present a pin to each of the new
officers
please hold your applause until the end
enzyme jacob dean asher
enzen asher is from coronado california
and has graduated with a degree
in economics from yale university enzyme
asher will serve as a student naval
aviator
at naval air station pensacola florida
[Applause]
enzyme isabella marie bach
enzyme bach is from herndon virginia and
has graduated with degrees in english
and russian from yale university
enzyme bach will serve as a submarine
warfare officer
at nuclear power training command in
charleston
south carolina
and then sofia ava bleak
enzyme bleak is from burning connecticut
and has graduated with a degree in
psychology from yale university
enzyme bleak will serve as a surface
warfare officer
aboard the uss dewey homeported in
yokosuka japan
and charles paul marker
ensign marker is from portsmouth rhode
island and has graduated with degrees in
mechanical engineering and history from
yale university
enzyme marker will serve as a student
naval aviator
at naval air station pensacola florida
[Applause]
second lieutenant valente hernandez
bautista
second lieutenant hernandez bautista is
from houma louisiana
and has graduated with a degree in
political science from yale university
second lieutenant hernandez bautista
will attend the basic school
at marine corps base quantico virginia
[Applause]
second lieutenant k lee second
lieutenant lee
is from westborough massachusetts and
has graduated with degrees
in global affairs and applied
mathematics from yale university
second lieutenant lee will attend the
basic school
at marine corps base quantico virginia
second lieutenant mohammed mahmoud
second lieutenant mahmoud is from
lilburn georgia
and has graduated with a degree in
global affairs from yale university
second lieutenant mahmoud will attend
the basic school
at marine corps base quantico virginia
[Applause]
staff sergeant allegra pancratz
staff sergeant parakratz is from wichita
kansas
and has graduated with a degree in
global affairs from yale university
staff sergeant pancratz will commission
as a second lieutenant this summer
and will attend the basic school at
marine corps base
quantico virginia staff sergeant
pancratz has been designated the
distinguished midshipmen graduate for
yale university
and rotc
second lieutenant fiona eileen asbury
lieutenant asbury is from potomac
maryland and has graduated with degrees
in east asian studies and economics from
yale university
lieutenant asbury will serve as a gold
bar recruiter at a location to be
determined
following which she will serve as a
space intelligence officer
at goodfellow air force base texas
lieutenant asbury has been designated as
an air force rotc distinguished graduate
a distinguished distinction earned by
the top 10
of cadets across the rotc enterprise
second lieutenant joshua charles beasley
lieutenant beasley is from herndon
virginia and has graduated with a degree
in computer science from yale university
lieutenant beasley will serve as a space
acquisitions officer
at los angeles air force base california
[Applause]
second lieutenant lauren ashley erhard
lieutenant erhard is from port jefferson
station new york
and has graduated with a degree in
criminal justice from the university of
new haven
lieutenant erhard will serve as a
security forces officer at malmstrom
air force base montana lieutenant
ehrhardt has been designated
an air force rotc distinguished graduate
a distinction earned by the top 10
percent of cadets across the rotc
enterprise
second lieutenant patrick harris hurl
lieutenant hurl is from plainville
connecticut and has graduated with
a juris doctor degree from quinnipiac
university school of law
lieutenant hurl will serve as a judge
advocate general
at maxwell air force base alabama
second lieutenant cheyenne combs
olmstead
lieutenant olmsted is from wilcott
connecticut and has graduated with a
degree in national security studies from
the university of new haven
lieutenant olmsted will serve as an
intelligence officer
at goodfellow air force base texas
second lieutenant tanner john tobritsky
lieutenant tavritsky is from phoenix
arizona and has graduated
with a degree in electrical engineering
from yale university
lieutenant tavritsky will serve as a
pilot trainee at a location to be
determined
second lieutenant tyler alexander
tavritzky
lieutenant tovritzky is from phoenix
arizona and has graduated with a degree
in mechanical engineering
and physics from yale university
lieutenant tobritsky will serve as a
space force developmental engineer
at los angeles air force base california
second lieutenant michael james english
whalen
lieutenant whalen is from new york city
new york and rome italy
and has graduated with a degree in
applied physics from yale university
lieutenant whalen will serve as a
special tactics officer
at lockland air force base texas
[Applause]
enzymes and lieutenants please rise to
be recognized
ladies and gentlemen i present to you
the newest second lieutenants and
enzymes of our united states armed
[Music]
forces
[Applause]
uh ladies and gentlemen please remain
standing for the playing of the marine
corps
navy air force and space force service
[Music]
songs
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
this concludes the 2021 joint military
commissioning ceremony
to our honored guests cadre cadets and
veterans
we wish you fair winds following seas
and blue
skies always
[Applause]
you